LA Times Kanye West hits keep coming
here the companies that have cut ties
within the Gap Instagram and Twitter
JPMorgan Chase Def Jam Balenciaga as I
said
c-a-a-mrc Adidas Foot Locker Jalen Brown
and Aaron Donald down to sports oh wow
is that it donda was just talking saying
that they were sticking with him
yesterday is this right but his lawyer
also uh he made sure that he's not
working with him his talented his lawyer
dropped him yeah his lawyer dropped him
his talent agency dropped him and now LA
Times is writing writing an article
talking about how Spotify and apple
music have to pull his music and they're
arguing for more censorship more
canceling here yeah L.A times has an
article that's titled why Spotify and
apple music haven't pulled Kanye West's
songs and in that article they make an
argument saying if we're going to
counsel somebody we're going to make
sure we're going to fully counsel this
person and you're seeing someone being
depersoned in real time whether you
agree with him or disagree with him I
think there is something to say about
something that has happened into Kanye
West right now that has happened
happened to other people like Alex Jones
and of course Andrew Tate as well look
at this donda's Kanye's company and
Jalen Brown and Aaron Donald cut ties
with donda that's what it is and they
got rid of the donda Academy basketball
team was removed from a tournament okay
what were you saying no it's just LA
Times here's the story what Spotify and
apple music haven't pulled Kanye West's
songs
this is the crazy thing about censorship
when Alex Jones got censored they didn't
shut down his ability to speak they
deleted everything he had ever said on
the platform on all these platforms
there's no record of it anymore that's
crazy that's like you know that what is
it photo of Stalin and there's that dude
next to him and then they got mad at the
dudes the dude's gone from the photo you
guys don't know yeah you guys you know
what I'm talking about you never saw
that no it's like a famous photograph
where it's like him with this guy and
then all of a sudden the guys watched
him out wow yeah yeah back in the day
before Photoshop same in one there's
like numerous people that he just you
know depersoned they got Kanye man
because he said oh now they're gonna get
mad at me for saying they no the The
Establishment the corporate press I
don't think here's the funny thing about
what Kanye said right so he criticized
the Jewish Mafia I think Kanye West is
clearly wrong about that I think he's
putting
needlessly putting like ethnicity and
race in front of what's clearly
corporate interests that are aligned
against him right but this is exactly
what conspiracy theorists and
anti-semitic individuals
expected to see and they and they got it
I got a question do any of you guys are
are any of you guys Jewish or do you
know a lot about Jewish Judaism in
general I talked with Michael malice
about it he's Jewish and was telling me
that there's like a tenet of Judaism and
get correct me if I'm wrong anybody in
the chat I want to get this as clear as
possible but that part of the uh Jewish
faith is that God commands people to
maybe not enjoy life on Earth but take
advantage of life on Earth this is
basically your opportunity and if you
don't take advantage of it then you're
basically committing a sin against God
so Jewish people believe that this is
Theirs to to mold and craft and utilize
but then what happens is that when that
gets out of control it can be perceived
as greed and that's completely
antithetical to Christianity which is
Charity greed isn't is a sin in the
Christian faith so
I think if when people get greedy that's
really the problem and when Kanye is
complaining about people he's
complaining about greedy people whether
or not they're Jewish I don't think is
relevant but it is interesting to point
out these these tenets of the Jewish
faith and I'd love to have Jewish
scholars in here to talk more about it I
found it interesting that they're not
canceling his music right I mean it's
it's it's a different situation when
okay you have a brand you have sneakers
or whatever it is that he's going to be
associated with but with the music it's
just him and so how much of the money
that that he's worth comes from his
music how much does he generate uh for
iTunes for Spotify obviously would be
hugely concerning if we start saying
we're not going to platform your music
um because of something that you said
outside of your music or even in your
music but if that's the next shoe to
drop I mean that's going to be a
problematic thing for everybody when
you're talking about censoring things
like music on on platforms what happens
after that so do you guys see when uh
remember when they banned Farrakhan I
think Facebook banned him basically what
happened is after Alex Jones gets banned
people start pointing out that uh
Farrakhan I don't know if for everybody
people aren't familiar it's the um
what's the organization called uh it's a
he not Hebrew Israelites no no no the
Muslim Brotherhood no it's not the
Muslim Brotherhood Nation of Islam
nation of Israel there you go yeah so uh
Farrakhan has is deeply anti-semitic
there's tons of people in the rap
hip-hop community and many people in the
black community who follow this he gets
banned and Snoop Dogg put out a video
saying how the f are you gonna ban
Minister Farrakhan you know how dare you
and stuff like that and it's fascinating
because it's like you do realize what
that means these people believe right
they're just not saying it so what
happens is people get surprised Kanye
West comes out and says this stuff I
wasn't I was on the ground in Baltimore
during the riots it was I can't remember
who the riots were for and there were a
bunch of young black kids who were very
very talking about they were talking
about Farrakhan they're talking about
Islam Allah and they were saying
anti-semitic things and that was the
first time I ever experienced it I
didn't know I was like what is this like
they're Islam or what's going on and
they both started talking to me about
you do realize like farrakhan's been
around for a really long time and then I
was like oh wow I've only remember from
rap lyrics and Tony Hawk uh two was a
Public Enemy song you know uh turned it
up Bring the noise that's what's called
Bring the Noise yeah when uh when when
um
what's the rapper Chucky D says
farrakhan's a prophet I think you ought
to listen to in the lyrics and then so I
didn't really know a whole lot about it
then I see these viral videos and I was
like that's what these people believe
holy crap so they banned the guy because
people started campaigning saying how
are you going to ban these people but
not him then a bunch of rappers
prominent celebrities people like Snoop
Dogg came out
Kanye West comes out and says I'm gonna
say what I feel like saying then he says
some anti-semitic BS and people are
surprised dude there's a ton of rappers
and celebrities who believe exactly what
Kanye is saying so I don't know I don't
know how you deal with it or or I'm just
I'm just pointing that out you want to
talk about banning his music which is
unrelated to his politics because he
admitted to what he believes think about
people like Snoop Dogg and all those
other people who support faricon yeah
another issue with Judaism and Islam
I've been thinking about is whereas
Judaism has this tentative like take
advantage of Earth utilize its goods and
it's gracious uh Islam is like do not be
decadent decadence is the bane of our if
you are decadent you are sinning against
God so whereas the judeo the Jewish
faith is kind of like maybe an opulence
maybe not the right word but they're
willing to have huge you know a lot of
things and stuff and good good things
around you Islam's like no no no no no
no no you do not want to show if your
brother is decadent he's a he's a stain
on the family so I think that's part of
why those two religions have been at
odds for so long I think
just coming into my mind the other day
yeah well you start you start Banning
music from today's era what do you do
from 150 years ago right that's a good
point classical musicians uh the Baroque
Era what were all their beliefs let's
let's get their beliefs and let's cancel
them off of you know wherever you get
your classical music from it's a
slippery slope that's so it's so weird
good point yeah this is just it it's I
shouldn't break it down shouldn't be
centralized yeah we can't we need like
decentralized music service like iTunes
should be a decentralized service in the
Commons where everybody can host their
stuff and and be utilized well you know
you know at the other side of this
private businesses get to choose who
they want to work with if they don't
want to work with this person they don't
have to but there also is a very
coordinated organized push to punish
people for expressing ideas that that
they don't like of course ideas always
should be debated always should be
contested uh I'm all for debate but you
know some people are saying Kanye is
going way too far it's too
sensationalistic and there's there's a
big Firestorm happening here there's
there's a lot of of media organization
saying cancel cancel cancel and a lot of
Corporations saying okay yeah gladly
we'll do it and they are so whether you
think it's right or wrong that's up to
you based on your individual you know
and all this is going to do is make him
double he's going to double down he
comes out and says he's being attacked
by you know a particular group then all
of a sudden everybody cancels and bans
him what do you think he's thinking
right now Kanye is probably being like
see see and it's like dude yes it's it's
it's just so insane man yeah I'm
surprised he wasn't able to sit down
with like the daily wire crew apparently
that's not going to happen Okay so they
didn't want him on on he said that on
the Lex Freeman interview he said it and
then Alexa's like wait they didn't want
you on and he was like yes they said
they didn't want me on that's crazy I
mean I get it you have to imagine Ben
Shapiro's like dude not cool I mean it's
like you know Ben's Jewish but I do
think communication is the solution I
have I mean unless you're going to try I
want to see a Kanye Ben Shapiro debate
it would be entertaining it would be
yeah crazy but would be a clash of
different ideas and as you mentioned Tim
you know a lot of people have those kind
of different ideas but but at the same
time what better way to deal with it
what better way to to get rid of a lot
of this animosity a lot of this hatred
than to be able to just to talk things
out and be able to of course pin ideas
against ideas let that let the best
ideas win and I think that would be
something interesting it might go
Haywire it might go bad but I I think
that's the consequences we face in our
modern day society and that's better
than just shunning someone and saying
hey now we're going to make sure you
double down on your beliefs instead of
talking you down from the beliefs that
we think are wrong yeah I gotta I'm
gonna have to hit up the daily wire crew
and ask them why that's the case because
that doesn't seem right sure good
clarification yeah because the daily
wire the the they like poking the bear
and and especially with Ben being Jewish
and Ben being reasonable I'd imagine Ben
would actually have a conversation with
Kanye Ben debates people he stands in
front of people so it seemed weird to me
that the daily wire wouldn't bring him
on you think they'd be the first first
place would be like okay Kanye like come
here and tell us why because we're going
to tell you why you're wrong but to just
be like no we won't have them seems
strange to me I don't know man yeah the
point you brought up you know I agree
right but you businesses can make their
choices on who they associate based on
you know what they want for their their
business model but Marketplace of ideas
I don't remember what Supreme Court
Justice said it back in the 30s or maybe
it was Holmes or Brandeis but the remedy
for bad speech is good speech exactly
right so you know absolutely 100 and we
need to prioritize that more more than
ever no matter who it is if you disagree
with again censorship only Fosters those
bad ideas and makes people double down
on them and when you censor people when
you silence people you only make sure
that they go off to the far ends of the
internet where those ideas are even
radicalized even more than they were
originally radicalized this is why I
have a lot of prospects and and a lot of
uh uh not pessimism optimism
specifically when it comes to Elon Musk
purchasing Twitter as I think it's going
to help Society by and large a lot
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there